-It´s been a very strange year
in football because I think
a lot of people like you
who love the game
and want to cover the game...
-Yeah.
-...all of a sudden, politics
has been a huge part of the NFL
this year, many have said
to its detriment.
Has it been frustrating being
in a position where you want
to talk about the sports
of it to also
have to balance it with...
-Sure.
Yeah, ´cause you know,
I have a Twitter account
where anytime something
like this comes up,
I get the "Stick to sports,
stick to football,
stick to something other
than the fact that you have
a mind of your own to
actually speak on something."
Which is what I view these
players who are taking a knee
before a game during
the National Anthem,
That they are having a moment
to try and bring attention
to an American experience that
maybe not everybody is aware of.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And yet, at the same time --
at the same time,
it´s fine that when I go to
a game and my kids are there,
I make them stand and put
their hand over their heart
and take their hat off and stand
for the National Anthem.
Just in the same way.
that´s what I want to do,
the players are doing this
not to be combative
towards first responders
or the military,
but rather to call attention
to something that they want
to have changed.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, I have met members
of the military who say,
"That´s why I fought."
I´ve met members of
the military who are offended.
I´ve met people who are fine
on either side.
And just having a conversation
is what I think this is
the most important thing.
-Do you think that --
Because I´ve watched
a lot of panels,
with people like yourself,
ex-coaches, ex-athletes
having conversations about this,
conversations that I had not
seen before on
these kind of shows.
Do you think those conversations
are getting through at all
to people, or do you think
people are so angry at one side
or the other there´s no sort
of amount of conversation?
-I think it´s both.
And it think it´s -- It´s both.
I think there are some people
who are hearing this
and understanding that
there is a larger picture
that the players are trying
to draw attention to.
And then there are others
who just are saying
they´re turning the sets off.
And to me, they´re missing
some really great football.
-Yeah.
-Quite honestly, but, you know.
That´s -- That´s something
tat I´ve seen for years,
is that there´s always going
to be something from outside
the football world that takes...
-Finds its way in.
-Right, that finds its way in.
In this case, having a national
conversation about it I think,
is fine.
I want to ask you
about this as well.
You´re not just a sports guy.
You do a lot of stuff.
You were an actor
in an episode of "CSI."
-Yes.
Well, I mean -- I would think
in quotes, "an actor."
-Well, no, you got a check.
So you are --
-This is great.
-´Cause you posted
this recently.
Who did you play on "CSI"?
-I think I played "Reporter."
-Reporter.
-Yeah.
-Oh, I remember.
You were great.
-Or -- or "Host."
Yeah, it was great.
-And you posted --
you got a residual check
for "CSI."
-I did, I did.
-Listen, for people
who don´t know, like,
when you´re in an episode
of a television show,
you just keep getting paid.
-Like it just --
like a slot machine.
It keeps paying out, man.
-And just to give you a sense
of a -- Here´s a check that
you received in the mail.
And if you can see the amount
there --
If you could zoom-in.
Right there, look at that.
98 cents.
-Look out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Feels like it´s not worth
sending a check for 98 cents.
-Well, what I did is I --
you know, I do whenever
I get those checks, I put them
on my Instagram account
with the hashtag --
´cause it´s "CSI Miami."
Not just any "SCI."
-Yeah, Miami, right.
-Seth, so the #suckitcaruso...
-Yeah.
-...always is on that.
So I took that check and a penny
and went to a 99-cent store
and just really partied
like it was 1999.
-There you go.
Well, thanks so much
for being here.
-I love it.
-I can´t wait to check you out
on Thursday.
-Thanks, buddy.
-Go Steelers, if you don´t mind.